[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale nous sommes le jeudi 23 décembre
voici des titres de cette édition
lundi une dizaine de jeunes ont pu
suivre un cours de soutien particulier
un atelier sur le thème coaching here is
it a pris place à montigny le bretonneux
objectif laisser tomber les croyances
limitantes et se construire des
objectifs en sport ce week-end le stade
français rencontrera le stade toulousain
le rugbyman yves binois léopard et est
mis au repos pour l'occasion retour sur
son début de saison dans ce journal le
chanteur en volutes infâme m vient de
sortir un nouveau titre sur le thème de
noël un duo avec la chanteuse américaine
heidi ricard son single christmas in
paris swing view est à découvrir dans
cette édition et puis tout au long de ce
journal nous vous emmènerons au coeur
des préparatifs et achats de dernière
minute avant noël nos journalistes sont
actuellement au centre commercial à
vélizy à 2 pour vous partager l'ambiance
sur place nous serons avec eux en duplex
[Musique]
avant cela l' agence régionale de santé
a présenté ce vendredi 17 décembre à sa
stratégie régionale des investissements
ségur en ile de france un investissement
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre du ségur de
la santé un plan mis en place par le
gouvernement pour épauler les
établissements sanitaires et médico
sociaux notamment pour la rénovation
encore la modernisation
2,4 milliards d'euros vont être investis
en ile de france dans les yvelines c'est
une soixantaine d'établissements
hospitaliers et de santé qui ont reçu
des aides financières une enveloppe de
256 millions d'euros pour porter des
projets comme par exemple centre
hospitalier de poissy saint germain et
celui de versailles ou encore celui de
rambouillet
faut-il faire du soutien scolaire
pendant les vacances le centre
excellence soutien scolaire à montigny
le bretonneux qui encadre tout au long
de l'année des séances de rattrapage en
mathématiques français anglais ou encore
en physique après a profité de la
coupure pour animer en fait un atelier
inhabituel le reportage de bixente
mayence anti steban
et si vous faites parce que vous
vous allez
le soutien scolaire c'est d'habitude du
français des maths de la physique le
centre excellent soutien scolaire a
profité des vacances pour expérimenter
un nouvel atelier à une dizaine de
collégiens et lycéens le thème coaching
et réussit on a pu débattre en étant à
l'aise on a travaillé sur le fil aux
objectifs et mettant vraiment nouveau
bassin de me lever plus tôt pour être en
bonne forme toute la journée ont relâché
un peu la pression n'est plus on est
plus à l'écouté finalement parce qu'un
élève qui est voilà demain j'ai un
contrôle la semaine prochaine j'ai un
devoir à rendre donc il a un peu pris
dans sa tête de faire ça et en plus un
début de vacances on sait que il a un
peu coupé avec l'école et je trouve ça
bien justement de profiter de cette
coupure pour aller parler d'autre chose
en toute tranquillité finalement parmi
les axes des trois heures de travail de
la matinée lutter contre ces croyances
limitantes une barrière mentale qui nous
empêche d'entreprendre ou de rêver pour
les mathématiques on est très souvent
conditionnés à ne pas y arriver parce
que depuis tout petit on entend que les
maths c'est quelque chose super dur
super compliqué tout ça ce sont des
croyances limitantes il y avait un élève
qui me disait moi j'aimerais bien gagner
dix mille euros par mois mais toute
façon je sais que je pourrai pas bah ça
c'est une croyances limitantes pourquoi
tu te dis déjà à treize ans que tu
pourras pas gagné dix mille euros par
mois c'est pas possible les élèves ont
ainsi pu se construire une liste
d'objectifs de vie à court et long terme
afin de trouver la motivation et une
raison pour mieux travailler je sais
pertinemment que les objectifs qui vont
se fixer maintenant à 13 14 voire 15 ans
ne seront peut-être pas ce qu'ils auront
à 25 ou 30 ans pour moi ce qui est
important c'est qu'il en est un c'est
important quand vous jouez dans votre
jeu vidéo de savoir quel est le but du
jeu sinon c'est la meilleure façon de
perdre le centre excellent soutien
scolaire souhaite mettre en place
d'autres ateliers de ce genre et des
activités extrascolaires comme le codage
ou la sensibilisation à des domaines
d'études peu connue des jeunes
et je vous disais en titre tout au long
de ce journal nous retrouverons nos
journalistes qui sont sur le terrain au
centre commercial à vélizy 2 pour nous
partager l'ambiance à 24 heures du
réveillon
et me caler louis d'auroure vous êtes
sur place justement vous êtes on a
exporté les 78 je vois vous êtes
accompagné à de jonathan thonon le
directeur du centre
exactement justin à mes côtés jonathan
tout le monde alors jonathan on voit
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui
dans les boutiques et oui le 23 décembre
c'est une très grosse journée pour les
clients et les commerçants c'est le
grand rendez vous de l'année pour
préparer noël il ya combien de personnes
environ qui passe qui transitent par
vélizy 2 ces derniers jours ah c'est de
loin notre plus grosse journée en terme
d'affluence
on enregistre une progression d'à peu
près 30% par rapport à une journée
habituelle donc c'est vraiment la plus
grosse journée de l'année bien sûr avant
les sols et les autres rendez vous alors
vous me l'avez dit hors antenne il y à
beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui mais il ya
beaucoup de monde depuis une semaine
environ oui c'est une de la féerie de
noël s'opère depuis le 20 novembre
on a installé une nouvelle décoration
noël on a installé le stand du père noël
et puis l'affluence l'activité va
crescendo jusqu'au 23 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et donc c'est tout une
fourmilière qui se met en place on avait
des commerçants des renforts aux équipes
qui ont aussi renforcé pour accueillir
cette activité
et ça monte crescendo depuis mi-novembre
et dans tout type de commerçants voient
derrière nous il ya des bijoutiers il ya
également aux chantiers qui l'est tout
au fond d'eux de vélizy 2 qui a
également beaucoup de clients
aujourd'hui et notamment sur
l'alimentaire oui c'est un grand rendez
vous pour nous de nos 200 enseignes
effectivement on représente tous
secteurs d'activité c'est à la fois
l'hypermarché auchan qui va être bien
sûr plus sûr de l'alimentaire avec les
huîtres les métiers de bouche de foie
gras et tous ces mets gourmets mais
aussi les secteurs de la santé beauté de
la cosmétique de l'informatique de la
mode de la décoration voilà c'est
vraiment
un moment très fort voilà pour toutes
les enseignes centre commercial et
comment on fait pour vous organiser
également vu le contexte sanitaire du
moment alors on est quand même assez
rodé maintenant
il ya beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui je
pense que vous le voyez les gens sourire
les gens sont nombreux je pense que les
gens et c'est important nous ferons
confiance depuis mars 2020 on a montré
notre sérieux alors on est bien sûr très
respectueux des consignes des autorités
sanitaires et préfectorale pour les
consignes on a des centres de dépistage
avec notre pharmacien on a un centre de
vaccination on a vacciné quasiment 90
mille personnes depuis juin dernier donc
les clients viennent chez nous et ils
vont aussi se faire dépister se faire
vacciner et puis après il ya tout ce que
vous voyez autour de vous de la
cinétique au sol verticale pour diriger
les flux dans un sens port du masque à
peine micro bornes de gel et bien sûr
beaucoup d'argent pour faire respecter
ces mesures et s'assurait que soient
bien appliquées vous attendent également
beaucoup de monde dans les prochains
jours où ça va se calmer un petit peu à
partir de demain alors c'est un bon
point et effectivement il ya un point
d'orgue aujourd'hui on sait la journée
la plus importante de l'année
aujourd'hui le 23 décembre demain c'est
plus calme puisque les gens vont chez se
préparer à leur table leurs cadeaux à
leur cérémonie
alors c'est leur célébration en famille
et après ça repart jusqu'au 31 le
réveillon donc finalement on est sûrs
quasiment des gros ce samedi jusqu'à la
rentrée des classes le 3 janvier la
question est ce que ça vous surprend ou
pas ce dernier rush chaque année vous
êtes directeur ici à wall street depuis
quelques années est ce que ça vous
surprend chaque fois
oui c'est toujours pro mais en fait on
est un peu plus pareil on a toujours
beaucoup de bonnes intentions à faire
les cadeaux en anticipation bien préparé
en avance et finalement pour pousser un
petit peu le dernier jour les derniers
jours
moi comme vous est peut-être comme tous
ses clients qu'on voit aujourd'hui ce
soir dont la joie la bonne humeur et la
féerie noël donc c'est plus important
merci beaucoup je m'attends tout le
monde et vous l'avez constaté justin il
ya énormément de monde ici à bdx gelé
constaté en effet merci beaucoup mais
quels ennemis devront vous reprendra
dans un instant mais pour l'heure c'est
aussi noël à versailles jusqu'au 2
janvier 2022 la salle des fêtes de
l'hôtel de ville est envahie par des
petits bonhommes en plastique les
playmobil un noël un noël fantastique
c'est une exposition pour transmettre
l'univers et le jouer l'esprit de noël
c'est le reportage de céline un gars de
100 go et bixente myers entité ban il ya
des pistes de ski et il ya aussi les
chalets ya les personnes qui seront
sauvés et à même les télécabines entre
stations de ski monde sous-marin château
fort ou jungle féerique l'exposition
playmobil un noël fantastique c'est 100
m² de nombreux univers à retrouver à
l'hôtel de ville de versailles j'ai
préféré à l'atelier du père noël lui
cherche sûrement beaucoup aimé ya plein
de sortes et depuis mobile imaginons ya
quelqu'un qui aime bien les châteaux
forts et ben il va trouver son secteur
avec les châteaux forts une exposition
qui mêle toutes les générations je
savais pas qu'il y avait ça à versailles
et pourtant je suis dit suis dit si
c'est mon ami qui me a fait kimi a fait
penser et donc on s'est retrouvés ici et
je regrette pas d'être venu même
certains pourtant très familier de la
mairie je m'amuse beaucoup parce que
maintenant quand je rentre dans la
mairie où on est accueilli par les
personnages playmobil mes grands
et pour la moitié d'une taille de
l'offre
et donc
on peut alors comment tu lui sysmans ya
des sapins chose comme ça c'est un côté
très festive un espace qui réveille des
souvenirs nostalgiques de jeunesse kato
fort parce que c'est un peu mon rêve
d'enfance qui a pu se réaliser j'avais
pas de château forgé j'avais dû
reconstruire en carton pour mes
playmobil à moins pas plus mobile ça
traverse les âges moi même
j'ai joué quand j'étais enfant je
passais des journées entières autour de
ces thèmes est donc là ça me replonge un
peu dans alors toute cette belle époque
impossible de savoir combien de
playmobil ont été placés dans l'enceinte
même pour le créateur de l'exposition ça
c'est la question piège auquel je peux
absolument jamais répondre parce qu'on
vient avec des caisses et des caisses et
on ne compte pas le nombre qu'on en mai
et enfin mes tubes de playmobil déjà
qu'ils sont sur la table l'exposition
est gratuite et accessible jusqu'au 2
janvier prochain et pour tous ceux qui
veulent ramener un peu de cet univers à
la maison des playmobil à l'unité ou
encore des pièces de collection sont à
vendre
toujours à versailles mais cette fois ci
du côté du château le temps mais aussi l
l'espace est suspendu pendant plus d'un
an si vous visitez prochainement le site
un élément sera manquant au premier
étage c'est la prestigieuse pendule de
louis 15 celles qui donnent les minutes
les heures le jour mais aussi la
position des planètes et les phases de
la lune elle est supposée se trouvait
dans le petit appartement du roi mais
elle a été amenée chez des spécialistes
pour une rénovation importante qui
durera plus d'un an le but faire qu'à
son retour elle puisse fonctionner
jusqu'à l'année
9999 un retour en grande pompe est
prévue en octobre 2022 lors d'une
exposition consacrée à louis 15
[Musique]
est à présent comme tout à l'heure on
retrouve mickaël hay et demi d'euros
auquel évident vous êtes sur place
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter un
peu vous nous dire un peu l'ambiance
alors il ya énormément de monde on l'a
dit a précédemment et je suis aux côtés
de 3,3 jeunes qui ont fait leurs cadeaux
à la dernière minute on peut le dire a
marre quand c'est bien ça reste et ça
lâche ya les petits tops des t-shirts de
t-shirts pour 30 euros j'ai acheté ça
pour ma soeur va être content de ces
carrés et pourquoi la dernière minute
bah je n'avais pas d'idée cadeau j'ai vu
sur instagram qu'il faisait désordre des
t-shirts du coup je suis venu avec des
idées directement et vous l'avaient
accompagné c'est ça charles et c'est sa
balle a du coup on va essayer aussi de
trouver des petits cadeaux la dernière
minute aussi pour la famille et wallons
et là c'est vraiment dernière dernière
minute parce que vous êtes arrivé il ya
quoi une vingtaine de minutes environ
tellement de qu'on arrivait il ya 20
minutes il voulait acheter un cadeau
pour sa soeur et moi j'en ai profité
aussi pour
essayez trouver un cadeau pour ma tante
on verra ce qu'on peut trouver bon c'est
un peu compliqué il ya beaucoup de monde
actuellement j'ai chaud vous connaissiez
de faire un peu rapide c'est pas trop
compliqué justement de faire les courses
à la dernière minute non parce qu'on
sent l'esprit des fêtes les vendeurs qui
veulent nous aider parce que c'est merry
christmas
merci merci en tout cas à tous les 3es
roulettes bon shopping tout simplement
voilà justin vous l'aurez compris les
achats dernière minute c'est pour tout
le monde moi même je vais continuer mes
achats et je vous laisse avec nicolas
landry je vous laisse continuer vos
achats merci beaucoup michael almy
d'euros journaliste à tv 78 on passe
côté sport à présent nous suivons
régulièrement son évolution sur tv 78 le
rugbyman yvelinois léobard et poursuit
sa progression au stade français de
paris ce dimanche 27 décembre le club
parisien on rencontre le club toulousain
mis au repos ce week-end le jeune joueur
du stade français a eu beaucoup de temps
de jeu depuis ce début de saison retour
sur ses performances avec l nicolas
landry à bixente mayence entité ban
il a 19 ans et déjà neuf matches de top
14 jouée cette saison arrière polyvalent
léobard et couvre plusieurs postes au
stade français paris demi d'ouverture
trois quarts centre ou arrière issus du
club de versailles il poursuit sa
progression avec l'équipe
professionnelle parisienne et dans le
mille de jeu puis surtout une continuité
cercle
cinq matches d'affilée à chaque fois
après ils m'ont laissé au repos 24 et
c'était plutôt c'était plutôt
intéressant pour moi d'évoluer avec les
banques parmi ces prestations cette
saison une rencontre à perpignan le
jeune joueur du stade français c'est
être décisif pour son équipe sur une
pénalité il a inscrit les trois points
de la victoire
après quand j'ai regardé le match et
beaucoup d'ambiance mais à aimé giral
mais pour le match et ben on est dans
notre bulle donc ça ça a beaucoup joué
et est arrivé au stade français paris à
l'été 2001 léobard et a prolongé son
contrat dans le club parisien jusqu'en
2025 une satisfaction pour le manager de
l'équipe gonzalo quesada beaucoup de
talent mais aussi beaucoup de qualités
de travail il ya encore du travail pour
lui pour pour être un grand joueur
installé au moins en top 14 il fait
partie de ceux qui font le délice ans et
d'humilité de la lucidité
ddd savoir qui a qu'un parcours encore
encore devant lui à faire mais c'est sûr
qu'il sera un des rares joueurs qui
aujourd'hui on
il a 19 ans et oran l'oubli quoi on
oublie tout cas 19 à léobard et joue
aussi en équipe de france moins de 20
ans avait quatre sélections à son
compteur il participera début janvier à
un stage de préparation en vue du
tournoi des six nations 2022
et on continue ce soir notre fil rouge
avec nos journalistes présents
actuellement au centre commercial vélizy
2 et je vois nicolas maury vous êtes sur
place cette fois-ci c'est vous que l'on
retrouvé vous êtes accompagné de laurent
seront-ils directeur de la fnac
effectivement justin michael est allé
faire ses courses de dernière minute en
minute et moi j'suis avec laurent
ferrandi vous l'avez dit donc le
directeur d'un grand magasin de produits
culturels bonsoir bonsoir alors comment
ça se passait en ce moment ça doit être
la cohue dans vos rayons écoutez ça se
passe très bien les clients sont au
rendez-vous le magasin reste quand même
puis l'organisation est bonne il ya de
quoi passer les derniers achats de noël
en toute tranquillité sachant qu'en plus
les prends du goût vendée on les
retrouve souvent sous les sapins
exactement là on est plutôt sur les
achats de dernière minute ça pousse fort
sur les produits éditoriaux ce qu'on
appelle chez nous comme le livre le
livre qui marche toujours aussi bien
chez nous avec par exemple deux exemples
la bd qui fonctionne extrêmement bien et
puis la poussée très forte du manga je
donne juste un exemple sur le tome sans
de one piece qui vient de sortir les
trois premiers jours c'est 130 mille
pièces qui sont partis et quel bilan
quel premier bilan vous pouvez faire de
ce noël 2021 chez vous côté le bilan il
est bon noël s'est passé un peu
différemment c'est plus c'est allé
depuis novembre c'est un petit peu dur
de la commencer à dire ce que va être
l'atterrissage je pense qu'à la fin de
noël on pourra dire effectivement ça
c'est bien ou pas bien passé mais pour
le moment ça se passera bien par exemple
l'année dernière c'est plutôt une
meilleure année que 2020 on est sur une
meilleure année en tout cas pour nous
avec la complémentarité de fnac.com ça
se passe très très bien parce que ça se
passe aussi sur le digital c'est
exactement ce et les interactions entre
les magasins et le web qui fonctionne
très bien aujourd'hui et malgré le
digital il ya quand même beaucoup de
monde dans le magasin il reste beaucoup
de monde en en présentiel bien sûr je
vais vous donner un chiffre aujourd'hui
nous allons rentrer plus de 16 mille
clients dans votre magasin et voilà
justin alors je sais que vous êtes vous
aimez les jeux de société je pense que
on peut trouver des jeux de société chez
vous beaucoup encore ya de quoi faire
bon ça ferme à 21h c'est ça je pense
justin que vous avez le temps je pense
que je crois qu'ils savoir qui vous
manque quelques cadeaux à faire non oui
c'est vrai nicolas landry merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là avec nous et puis si vous
voulez faire vos derniers achats ou
d'acheter des jeux de société à c'est le
moment allez-y
merci beaucoup
on l'a appris on l'a appris cette
semaine la 49e édition de la corrida de
houille est annulé l événement qui
devait se tenir mercredi 26 décembre ne
pourra pas avoir lieu en raison de la
crise sanitaire et suivant les
recommandations du préfet l année
dernière la pandémie avait aussi
empêcher la manifestation de se tenir
pour rappel la corrida de huy est une
course pédestre annuelle de 10 km qui se
déroule dans les rues ou milloise
et puis le chanteur rend polita un fab m
a sorti un nouveau single pour noël
toujours christmas in paris with you
c'est en duo avec la chanteuse
américaine a dit erica leur clip est
sorti le 12 décembre écoutez le clip de
file m suivi est d'un extrait de
l'auteur
[Musique]
oui
c'est le fruit d'une collaboration avec
l'oeil d'eric attias une chanteuse
américaine qui viennent des trois on n'a
pas collaboré ensemble sur mon dernier
album verra notre matin où elle est
venue chanter sur une chanson qui
s'appelle you say you say et m'a demandé
pour son christmas album de composer un
duo avec elle donc elle est venue tout
noir de détroit pour qu'on compose
ensemble ensemble cette chanson et voilà
donc on a sorti le single cette année
on imaginer voilà une américaine qui
fait pour le coup le new yorkais est ce
qui fait son son tour du monde et qui
arrivent en france tombe amoureuse d'un
français et les deux voilà les deux ont
une espèce de nostalgie et et ne
souhaite qu'une seule chose c'est de se
retrouver voilà le rendez-vous parfait
pour se retrouver ce sera noël à paris
quand on est vraiment tombé dans le dans
la chanson romantique on
on reçoit une touriste américaine où
est-ce qu'on l'emmène emmène bien
évidemment à paris on va en votre cadero
on va sur les champs-elysées avoir
marché de noël et voilà l'idée était
vraiment de rentrée en plein dans la
chanson ou d'illustrer la chanson à
travers les images
[Musique]
offertes mini album un ep pop qui sera
pas forcément en rapport avec noël et
qui va sortir au printemps on a tout
enregistré à l'eal elle est venue en
france pendant un mois et demi pendant
un mois et demi on a bossé tous les
jours pour faire un album de noël et
ensuite un mini album tous les deux
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi je vous souhaite à
toutes et tous de très belles fêtes de
fin d'année de la part de toute l'équipe
de tv 78 et surtout prenez soin de vous
[Musique]